hi we're the cast of Riverdale and I'm
Kasey Kahne and we are going to do a
water video not yet yeah well not
definition okay why are Riverdale
character is named after Archie well so
our characters are that of Archie comics
why Riverdale is the best you know what
it's yourself because the fans it's cuz
of kzkz well I mean go on I searched
that exact query probably two thousand
times
[Laughter]
Riverdale away okay turn into a music
hall yes sometimes let succeed Jughead
sing very Johnny Cash meet Eminem
Riverdale guy is your perfect match
what quiz and wasn't me it was anyway is
your perfect match over Rio guys moose
mine's definitely how Cooper what if
wins a girl
what year is Riverdale sentence that's a
great that's a good question we don't
have respect it's sudden next year we
intentionally do not clarify the year or
the timeframe of the show yeah yeah but
we all know but you don't
where is Riverdale supposed to be River
down on the East Coast right all right
wrap dress is you wanna do it first one
share the honors Cole Sprouse
Tim Cody or Zack Cody Cody his life so
sweet
feels like it's both breath its cause
for us you know
oh my god he's brew is emo cross
prospect no I am father rouse star sign
leo yeah what camera is Cole Sprouse
using I'm not going to tell you guys I
will spoil that it's a iPhone is Lilly
Reinhart daddy or London singing yeah
always I think it's I guess she's
singing in the musical episode oh yeah
yeah yes she would not choice is Lilly
Reinhart related to judge Reinhardt next
k pi q is it Lee Reinhard
nether like from the Netherlands I think
that would have neater layout
guys you heard of here first answers yes
look like Brittany Murphy I know you do
want to know our attorney people Lord of
the Rings oh thanks yes four of them was
Lee Reinhard in Gossip Girls no yeah yes
she blazed a Leroy yeah she's the
girl at gossips Le Pen how to pronounce
Madeleine pet not only me but that
little peasant doesn't eat nothing
lutely nothing no pet shop product a
beautifully a ripe tomato that's ginger
now it's really baby you know it it's
all natural
I can see her ribs
hey they're green and they have a little
bit of yellow in the middle are you sure
they're green kind of brownish great
yeah all right who is Casey cop
this guy TVs basil that's depressing no
man snapchat don't have one
despite God have a twin no but my sister
is alive
what's Vanessa Morgan's favorite color
baby blue mmm she knew that what does
Vanessa Morgan look like now vegan no no
no she's not no she's not
no she was here she's a liar she was big
there's some snake 19th March 23rd 1992
how to draw Vanessa Morgan how to draw
people dude I'm not a guitarist like
very Titanic question with pastels of
course why is he all rich in South Park
uh-huh because I allowed them to use me
that's right be a boss oh I know it you
don't have to Brian Brian what's the
last name trouble try and trust where
are you all right now right there oh
dear where nature where is where the
name a genomic from German German means
little girl in German looks little
maiden eat someone who by fire major
right yes me what it means husband Oh
David Alexis
in the world 31-year love affair Wow
Anna cool dude where was ancient amick
born hurry no Nevada yeah let's do that